okay all right we are the second of
back-to-back design meetings that we're
live-streaming this one is hopefully the
end of the story of network packet
capturing for 11.3 and what we're trying
to deal with is we have agreed that
there are many different ways that one
might want to have interfaces to
real-time data acquisition functions
from ones that are pretty much pure
programmatic say record this for X
number of seconds to ones that have a
GUI and so on I mean I think one of the
things that I think we're convinced of I
think but I'd like to confirm that is
that that the GUI and the programmatic
versions of these functions have to be
distinct do we agree
so for example audio capture which is
the direct analog of Network packet
capture it is a distinct function
from anything that does
just capture order Oh for X number of
seconds or something so this thing here
oh gosh we still got this what why
haven't we got the new graphic design of
this anyway I've just been really really
busy okay all right fine
but the design is made right so it's a
question okay all right um okay so the
issue right now is given this network
packet capture mechanism we're going to
have a function network packet recording
which is the purely programmatic just go
out and fetch these packets but we need
to design what the actual argument
structure of this is and reminding
ourselves Network packet capture
oops that's not what I meant I meant
network packet no network pack capture
that's right so that is being given
that is being prompted with a certain
service or a certain spec
right so for example I could say
something like what can I say for
Network packet capture I could say
something like port
how do I do that how do I say just port
80
well I mean in the in the documentation
page you would just say 80 as a number
that's no well let's imagine that I want
to do ports above let's say I want to do
ports below 80 okay how would I say that
so I mean this won't work in the bill
but you'd use interval okay but isn't
there a way of giving a spec
right you do you do pork goes to
interval from I guess 0 to 80 okay so
there are no more general Klan probably
span is yeah I think span is better than
interval
we document the fact that we support
spam I mean I have an implement I mean
if you want I can add span I think you
want something that doesn't expand
otherwise range would be fine but span
stays as is it's a short specification
right but now but the specific the spec
here is a purely it's a static spec it's
not an arbitrary function or anything
like that
you
is that correct on the livestream
somebody is suggesting between and what
the
it's a discrete sets
well it is a discrete set but there's
you see the problem is that between is
really a querying function and you know
that would be more like what we've done
in some of these other cases where for
example if we say you know whatever it's
Buddha's are called fate face
I find faces right so in find faces
there is a function that is the
criterion for what the face that you're
finding is and that function
is where is it
maybe it isn't in the documentation yet
um where you can say you know hash age
greater than whatever for find faces and
so that we could imagine here we go um
am I am I wrong yeah there we go
hash feature bla bla bla bla bla
right
similar thing for network packet capture
where you're taking all of these things
all of these things and you're saying
things like hash port is greater than 80
or something
that makes sense or is that impossible
or what what's the story so now you're
here wanting to use slots like named
slots well it's what we've done in some
other places I mean here what you're
doing is you're saying port arrow such
and such a thing right yes
so you're you're basically describing
what you want using an association which
is analogous to what we do in something
like text search
right
I mean there's really three different
things running around here one is the
case of associations and text search and
so on where you're basically just saying
this field value is this or similarly
from a form another case is the case of
something like implicit entities where
you're able to give a function on the
right hand side of the property value
and the final one is what we're doing is
a criterion and things like find faces
where you're basically saying a function
applied to the Association that's being
returned
see for example in the case of this
every every line here is an association
right
and I mean yeah yeah sorry I didn't
realize
oops the so this is just some random
however
okay so that's a random Association that
has all this information like source
port and so on so in principle if I said
or if I for example said um the UM you
know if I took this association but
you're saying that what we can do anyway
will be something like in here I could
say that's a data set and I could say
select
hache source port if I'm not mistaken
greater than fifty thousand that right
is that going to work that should work
yes
that's pretty cool
oh for goodness sake do that why is it
doing this this window tracking thing is
broken um okay so your argument might be
that's good enough and by the way we
should make sure we have examples that
show things like this
can we make sure that yes yeah
the um so data set syntax that we're
using right that works yeah yeah yeah
right exactly but the question is
whether we need to filter it source or
whether filtering here is enough no we
do need filter at source right because
you could be having like hundreds or
thousands of these packets coming in and
so the ability to filter them at the
source right but we don't have the
ability to filter them this way at the
source we have the ability to do certain
filtering at the source efficiently yeah
yeah yeah okay sorry I misunderstood the
query with source port greater than
fifty thousand you could represent that
with a range you could go fifty thousand
I understand but that's completely
different syntax that you're talking
about there so that that's a network
packet capture and then we will be
saying um
of port arrow and one possibility here
will be to do it like to allow the
possibility of doing it like um in
implicit entities where we would just
say greater than
such-and-such I'm making sense as
opposed to what you're doing right now
which is to say Network packet capture
of port 80 for example that didn't work
why didn't that work because it's just
an association
work or should it go in an association
there I mean I just I mean we can
support the naked rule that's fine I
don't should we need to okay that's
easier for me okay so the spec
says here can be given in the form
kierra value or as an association so it
claims that that is supported so if it
we all have to change that claim or
support it
okay I mean it's up to you if he knew I
initially did not have key goes to value
as a single rule and then you wanted to
add that but I haven't had time to
implement that yet so now we'll be
visiting this so it's up to you I think
we should I think we should have it but
I'm not that passionate about it um
you
let's okay let's let's do the rest of
the design then let's loop back to this
okay so the rest of the design has to do
with what how to specify so what we have
here is um
the we can specify it by time so if we
could network packet recording we can
say so right now if you say point 1 here
or point 0 5 or something that's simply
going to be that number of seconds right
yep okay so the things that we care
about are in terms of defining that we
kept we went through this yesterday do
we have the document from this please
whose peeling Here I am and where is the
document the one from yesterday the one
from yesterday
yes that it's in your Dropbox and CSC so
I LD SW notes and then of course uh
Priory
okay and then what network packet
capture 2:02 okay all right here we go
okay this is all right so these are the
right these are the parameters that
determine how much recording to do if
I'm not mistaken
Ian yes that is correct those are the
only ones well I mean yeah so so you
know so mention making the expression
case into a different country I know
that but but we're coming back to the
question of calculated in the same
function
I mean potentially yeah but those are
the only three specifications okay okay
but we've also got then so we've really
got two different pieces we've got how
long to record and what to record right
correct yep um
actually someone on the livestream is
asking can we apply a domain name filter
have it automatically do the DNS lookup
for you and show packets for any
destination IP matching the DNS records
interesting so I mean that would be
doing the host lookup
if I'm not mistaken from
you
that's not right well yeah I mean so I
think the the real thing they're asking
is have it have because pcap can do this
when at the source level base what is
this not working what am i oh is that is
that am I going the wrong way around I
don't how do I do the lookup from the IP
address I think that's just a ballad or
I mean there's not a domain name
associated with that IP address dude I
mean if you do like host lookup of
Wolfram calm or something and then do
host lookup of the IP address you get
back from that that should work okay
you
okay so the question is is so what's the
interpret the question then okay so
Peter has the ability to filter by
domain name when it does doing the DNS
lookup at the source level as these
packets are being generated and it's a
little slower to do that that lookup so
for this initial release we weren't
going to support doing that at the
source level we were just gonna do IP
address because it's a little bit more
work at it slower to do domain name but
so what will we do syntactically if we
wanted it to be by domain name we would
have to have in our set of criteria we'd
have to look at so what will all be the
idea for how that would work in the spec
here we would have to say domain name or
something is that correct yeah I would
say domain that's the most consistent
with URL read URL execute etcetera okay
so what we will be adding is something
here that says in addition to IP address
we would have something that says um
here we would have something that
basically says domain
we would have a source domain
destination domain and everything right
just to remind ourselves that we need to
do this let's some let's but but that
that would be something that we would
that you could give us a criterion but
what about in the return values here you
would have to do the lookup yourself
because we don't want to take the extra
time to go find go do little time cuz it
does mean for a majority of these cases
I feel like there's not gonna be an
Associated domain name right for all
these like zoom servers and things for
me for you for your case I don't think
that domain names for all these and so
trying to do that look up because it'll
fail most of the time will be very
expensive in terms of time especially if
hundred yeah fair enough so then this is
the case where if there is a domain
associated with a particular so it so
just to add this it would be domain and
then it would be something like come
source domain destination domain is that
correct yeah that's right I mean I don't
know if you want to put it yeah I guess
below IP address make sense yeah and
then for right now we're just going to
future eyes these
ugh what did this just do
am I using some weird prototype build
here I am probably and this probably
refused to future eyes more than one
what on earth
well whatever okay it's a little funky
um
okay so looping back to the original
issue right so
again
for a network packet okay so we have not
discussed the possibility of having a
more sophisticated right-hand side for
this chiara value thing which I don't
think we should do right now um
and okay so it's oh wait a second so
then um
here we also want to talk about the use
of span
let's see elements such as
port can have values you know specified
values there's already a table of above
above about silly me okay
right okay but Roger is pointing out
that interval isn't really the right
thing it really should be span I mean
okay and we might as well support both
of them it doesn't really matter all
right any further so it doesn't it
doesn't
both we'll both should work yeah
okay so I think we should document spam
because I think it's the more consistent
thing but I think interval is fine to
support make sense
Oh
do we have to change this in the other
documentation as well I can do that as
long as one of the pages is up-to-date I
can okay alright but but we should
support span and interval both of them
okay um okay let's come back here again
to the main question we're trying to ask
which is what is the first argument of a
network packet recording and I think the
consistent thing to do would be to have
it be able to be an association um of
the kind that I specified here
now the only issue is with this
expression thing Roger you can you
comment on this please
expression well this thing here so so
the issue is
okay the issue is we've got these three
different cases they could overlap and
what do we do if they are okay first of
all it's I think you have if you allow
general code in general things you have
to have a very definite rule like first
two first two you know besides so what
can we pour in is that easy to do what
can we do yeah I mean rule delay this is
that's ideal because for example you
don't want it to evaluate no no no no
I'm asking a different question we've
got three different criteria duration
packet count and evaluation duration of
an expression right yes so what I want
to understand is we could do a design
where so first question is what should
the defaults be if you just give point
one does it mean point one seconds or
point one packets received I think
numbers should be interpreted as time
because that's I think the most common
use case where people are just like I
want to record for 10 seconds or five
seconds or whatever so I think number
like just a bare number that should be
the duration it's my argument for the I
respond okay
well the argument against that is then
how would you specify packet count I
mean you don't put in association I
guess or or a rule like packet count
goes to ten or units does it but we do
have units for packets but we more and
easily have units for time all right
I I guess I'm prepared to go with this
um but then what let's take a look here
we are so right now we have this in oh
boy okay we have these things in a list
right the time and the service and so on
I think that's probably wrong and we
probably want to break those apart a
separate arguments do you agree or do
you not agree I agree okay
you can you just go ahead and do that
I'll break the first one here yep okay
fine
so then
okay so then the alternative form here
would be network packet recording of so
now there's two cases we have to cover
there's the packet count and there's
this expression thing okay
not super happy with this because I
don't think it makes a lot of sense to
get both I mean and maybe it does you
say it's either I want to record for 10
minutes or yeah it's not totally stupid
um that got a noise by the way um we've
either got you know I want to record
either for 10 minutes or until I've seen
a thousand packets am I making sense
yeah I mean that's a lot harder to
implement the the or condition
well what is easy too I mean if that
that would be the most useful thing so
what is the what is that I mean we're
right at the deadline here so what is
the easy thing to implement for this
experimental version the easy thing to
implement is to say if there are
multiple we either fail and just say you
can only have one of them well okay then
we can't have an association because
that doesn't make any sense okay or what
well we pick up the first one or
something I mean yeah we could pick up I
think the the safe design is that but we
do like you said where the first
argument is just how long to record and
for now we just support like a naked
rule for the other you know for duration
or whatever or not or a backpack account
rather and then later on maybe
12 or whatever then we support this
association which does the more
complicated you know either-or situation
and that that has you know okay how do
we deal with the expression case
Oh do we have another function
does it even work to imagine this okay
let's review what the expression case
does okay first of all I assume it is
implementable yes yes it's currently I
mean it the implementation right now
behind the scenes is actually a lot
closer to what audio record does is I
just start a stream and then pause for
however many seconds and and then stop
the stream and returns the data said so
okay but then how do you do it with this
expression instead of doing a pause you
evaluate the expression is that correct
exactly okay so one of the disadvantages
of this way of doing it is you don't get
the return value here
yeah I mean that the true do you care
about the wrong well I would think that
you yes for the same reason is when
you're doing absolute timing you care
about the return value sure you do I
think this is actually wrong because
okay so let's some
you
I mean if I say absolute timing then I
am timing how long something takes and I
am also getting the result right
and I think this is the same type of
thing let's see who the same case of of
absolute timing where you're saying give
me the absolute timing of this
expression in that case then maybe well
as you say network packet recording
could just support time and then we do
something else for earth sorry now we're
expected recording because it ends in
mic ing of an expression could could
operate the same way absolute timing
does then we have another function that
does the time of the packets there may
be um hey Roger what do you think
Roger
but Rogers not on zoom' I'm not sure
where he is right now
okay as I knowed here
yep yeah to have comments on this I'm
sorry I was on the chat answering
questions there were some questions
about other recordings that you made
about neural network so I was okay okay
okay so I am paying attention okay um so
let's see um the question is what is
happening here is similar to what
happens in absolute timing as in an
expression is evaluated but we want to
know something about how what happened
while that was going on and we might
want both things we might want both
absolute timing and network packet
recording and ian is pointing out I
think correctly that the network packet
recording sounds a lot more like you
know absolute timing and suggests that
the you know the thing that is most
analogous to that word packet recording
is device read time series except that
it happens to give a time series
and the the capture function is the one
that is giving the UI this is what is
okay so we've got these different cases
but it seems reasonable to me what it's
no no no but but but but but we've got
to actually decide on three if we're
going to have three different functions
we've got to figure out what they are
oh what's the third one capture
recording and what's the third one
capture generates a UI okay okay the
this one here what is currently called
Network packet recording simply
generates a data set okay I mean it is
in a sense but I don't like it Network
it no I don't like this at all
I don't like that I mean the the our log
here is there is current image which
goes ahead and captures an image right
and just returns the image I mean again
this is different in behavior than
network packet capture unlike image
capture which allows you to repeatedly
capture images it only does one right
it's a one-shot thing okay that's
doesn't make sense for network packets
unless you would have liked a current
network packet and if you want or
something that seems a little weird so I
don't see the Anala
the analogy there I know but but network
packet capture is the name that I think
is a good name for this one-shot yeah
for this thing that brings up a GUI
here's another so what if instead so we
have a function that specifically just
takes an expression um it does
so the expression version is the
different function now we could have it
be like you said network I can capture
our network packet recording during
which i think is very verbose or we can
have something a little bit simpler like
network packet activity of expert you
know network packet traffic of expert
something like that that's like here's
the traffic here's the activity during a
sick spray expression so we could do
network packets during expression so
we're just trying to separate them no no
because that has to return something
more like absolute timing that is it has
to return the packets and the result see
what I'm saying and I think that that
argument the read that it returning
something similar to absolute timing is
the best argument for it being a
different function Carlo who turns out
to be here as well is some assuming he
can actually speak what about something
with trace in it that word packet trace
I don't quite believe that especially
since trace in the in the world of
network packets means probably means
something different oh it would
yeah it would trace the network packets
during the evaluation of expression
that's not completely crazy I think I'll
capture things that are completely
unrelated to the evaluation of
expression that's not so different what
are you saying that were quite what were
you saying was not crazy Network packet
trace I don't believe in it because it
suggests tracing packets which suggests
going and looking you know like trace
route and things that work packets
during seems the least crazy of the
things that I've seen so far now the
only question is whether network packet
recording is the right name but are
other functions that we have and
enduring already answer I don't believe
so
okay but we don't have other functions
that do network packets while no because
that suggests a criterion and I'm just
brainstorming hmm well okay do we do we
think network packet recording is the
right name I mean I think it could also
alternatively be Network packet activity
or network packet traffic what's it
called in Wireshark does it have a name
there what once I can apply Wireshark oh
yeah but I don't know packet capture
that it doesn't make a lot of sense to
talk about both capture and traffic
perhaps capture is the wrong name no I
really like capture I think so and we
just have to find something analogous
okay well the analogous thing so in the
case of audio so Carlo can you speak to
the audio case we what did we agreed for
the case of record audio for one second
and just return it so that is not
lamented but we were thinking of just
having a lyrical having to just a third
the fire don't forget behavior but wait
a minute audio record returns an audio
stream
oh you occurred yes yes sorry sorry
I always thinking about audio recording
okay audio recording you just like
network packet recording it's a very
funny part of speech yes what is it that
it does it is I mean look at what it
okay what it says is records information
hmm what do we have that is similar to
this unfortunately what about gather
network Hackett gather I believe in that
reminds me of the whole gather gather by
family who have things um I also don't
really like the network packets plural
being used in this this form here um I
mean I agree network packet activity
don't know okay what are we got a lot of
synonyms for record record well I mean
we could go in a different direction
where it's the network network packet
data for example do we really have a
data function that you know has a time
kind of specifier no all the other data
functions are like yeah you're right
it's wrong um what let's let's look at
device read time series let's see
whether it references anything else
similar how great it references network
packet recording um accumulate assemble
a massive way to poetic no but why not
just describe what it is the problem is
that we've we've locked ourselves in
that packet capture which is kind of a
verb like I mean if we say ping time for
example right that just is a.m. I mean
what are the analogous things that we're
dealing with in a case like that let's
see
Network packet read them hmm
Network packet important that one is
more plausible I just don't know how to
get it to be easy to remember what is
capture versus you know how do we
remember what does capture do versus you
know which has a GUI versus a thing that
is purely programmatic see I kind of
think know what packet recording is
probably okay for what it is so then we
have to solve the problem of how do we
do
I mean potentially this crazy act thing
of just you know potentially you could
say you know you could want to record a
so here's a weird thing imagine you want
to record sounds while an expression is
being evaluated right how
earth would you do that where the things
we're currently specifying now you could
do that with the audio stop audio record
audio stop mechanism it's like mmm like
a block Network packet block or module
no but but it's like a scoping thing
right it like yes you really didn't get
evaluation so it's you know like I mean
blocking modular probably not the right
names but it's kind of like during the
scope of the evaluation of the
expression you want it to do something
that's correct so what are some options
there have I mean we could just forego
the expert version entirely and instead
do something similar to an audio record
just have network packet record with
reference so no because this is the most
useful case I mean this is what people
are actually gonna want to do much of
the time is they're gonna want to say I
want to run the sewer you know do this
URL execute and then I want to see what
happens network packet with it's not the
right way round with no it's not the
right way around I mean with would mean
yeah I know right there so there's
already a function called wizard
Elizabeth what about maybe analyze like
network packet analyze why would that it
doesn't make I mean it's gonna be very
hard to remember explain to me why
recording is different from analyze
what's it doing that you know what
analysis is there doing that the other
one isn't doing network packet
evaluation no I mean the problem is also
that realistically the network packets
may have absolutely nothing to do with
the expression yeah they could be just
drive by cosmic rays so to speak
um I mean I think during even though
it's kind of horrifying maybe the best
thing because it is at least the most
honest no it is a slightly bizarre thing
there are other words like during I mean
I don't dislike during but well the
other question is what comes before it
is it networks packets which I don't
think I mean probably the least crazy is
probably network packet recording during
but then you know noting that it's it's
return structure is different from
network packet recording but it's
otherwise it's identical other than I
mean that that's there's a certain you
know to come up with another name look I
think this is probably the right thing
network packet recording during somewhat
weird but probably right okay so so then
the this could either take one argument
which is expert which is give all
packets or the second argument just like
network packet recording the second
argument is the filter spec that is
correct
so um okay so then this would be network
packet recording during let's see if I
can make a typo in the basic function
okay so then this is let's look at how
absolute timing describes this whilst is
another synonym for during
Pyrates exper and returns a list of
network packets returns inflation on
network mic is transmitted or received
through all interfaces on your network
interface on your computer system during
the evaluation process time of the
evaluation during the time of the
evaluation together with the results of
the evaluation I think that's
what we want to say and then we want to
give the other arguments like port like
service and port and so on that make
sense yes yeah okay so if you can fill
those in that would be good and then we
have to say in the notes here I mean the
trivial things like let's see something
like this actually it should be hold not
hold all but hold first right yeah
and we probably should make this one we
should probably comment on this because
it's useful okay so we should also say
Network packet recording during um of
export dot records packets well it's
it's some starts recording packets I
think we could just say starts recording
packets when exper starts being
evaluated and ends recording stops
recording when it is finished I mean
that I mean couldn't we also just say
records packets while expert is being
evaluated a lot bigger okay fine well
then we're just repeating this I mean I
guess if we're just repeating that then
why right but what we what we want to
say is okay records all packets during
the evaluation of Hackett's packets
transmitted or received during the
evaluation of Expo whether or not they
were actually so during the time the
evaluation of exper whether or not they
are actually associated with the
evaluation process with the computation
with the evaluation process
maybe another way whether or not they
are actually generated by the evaluation
generated okay
generated by the evaluation
that's fine that's that's okay all right
okay well I think we've got a solution
here it's not the I mean I think this is
this is will be okay um and this is
certainly gonna be the I think it's
gonna be the most commonly used one of
these actually what was the second usage
snare with no arguments it's not the
second usage with arguments incorrectly
but it should be Expo commerce service
and this might want to have a time
constraint option if you can do it right
if the thing is really just like there's
an ever coming back you might want that
time constraint actually you know you
could do that but in the sense who cares
because you can wrap a time constraint
around the expo yeah I wouldn't bother
um okay
all right let's the clever tree here I
think I think this is okay I think we're
done now with the design for all the
network packet so you want enemy to fill
out the xxx is there
could you please yeah um if you can send
me a version that'd be nice but I think
I can count on you to just do this I
think it's pretty straightforward from
here on out we wait one trivial meeting
yes yes so we decided that for when
you're doing when you're trying to
specify the number of packets going back
to network packets recording the number
of packets is either specified as like a
qua quantity quantity of data packets
yes what was the other way that we are
going to allow this okay so network
packet recording I think we should say
packet count arrow n
used to
record exactly n packets
because I can imagine different cases
that you actually want here it might get
a little bit more sophisticated because
that assumes you're going to get n
packets that match your criteria correct
if you specify criteria yes right but
you might also want such-and-such a
number of source packets that is examine
a million packets and just return
whichever ones actually match the
criteria as opposed to this one which
says in the end I want n packets out
sorry mister you okay
so I mean one case is a million packets
came through the network interface only
six of them were things I cared about
okay
I want to examine a million packets to
find out the ones I care about
alternative I want to get a hundred
packets that I care about and I might
have to examine a hundred million
packets to get that yeah so the how
everything is implemented right now we
can't we can only do click we can only
do the case where you get back however
many packets you asked for we can't do
the case where you're like look at this
up to this many packets remember the
weather yeah okay let's let's put that
weird slightly weird usage in there and
leave it at that for now okay we have to
like have some experience with these
functions while they're still
experimental and I think this is okay
and by the way here we need to redo this
documentation because this has to say T
comma service etc etcetera etcetera
right and I'm messing up the way that
this is actually so to be T or should we
just do dot dot comma service just could
also be the pack account or a quantity
all right okay will do dot dot I mean I
can do this but I just wanted to confirm
that yeah I know no I agree that's
probably the right thing to do I was
thinking of that initially and then I
thought um okay oh here we need to be m
to change that to the span case
you
you
okay looking good all right and there's
actually one guide page change what the
heck I'll I'll put that in right now
since some what was the what was the
guide page for these things network
programming
you
you
you
you know we've been so confused about
this I'm kind of thinking we should
actually list these different cases here
um
you
oh what the heck I'll list one of them
let's just list the network packet
recording during
you
you
um
you
capture network activity during the
evaluation of an expression I mean
didn't we just say record surgery or
capture
you
and we have a rule that has to fit on
one line so record packets during the
evaluation of an expression okay and
actually let me let me while we're at it
doing this knitting let me let me put
this on the page for absolute timing and
things um
you
you
so this wants to be
tuning and debugging and time
measurement and optimization probably
tuning and debugging let's see where
would this go time
he goes under network connectivity
online
you
record network activity let's say cap
activity during an evaluation
you
okay
you
okay now do we want to also put this on
see what the other page was here um see
whether that fits on the optimization
page probably does not
maybe maybe under the network timing
section
I don't think so really unless we have
no because this is mostly just literally
how long did it take which is a
different question so I think we're good
here one last thing that design
debugging about they think that it's
best to get rid of the pause button do
you want to keep the pause button in the
capture dialogue I have no opinion about
the pause button I think the pause
button is probably fairly weird okay
yeah because I that's kind of what I was
thinking is is that you know you want to
start recording and then stop and that
there's no I mean for audio makes a
little bit of sense if you want to
record while some other event just going
on and just pause well something else
happens
yeah then resume again but I don't think
that exists with network packets I agree
okay we will mix the pause button okay
all right
are we done here I think so
great okay long road but I think we made
it um and these will be nice and useful
functions all right yeah thank you guys
soon okay